with the addition of these concepts the
maps gotten a lot more complicated let's
start by looking at this spot the thing
that goes here has to be a type of clone
and it's a part of github so it'll be
something that's github specific and not
a part of the original get system it's
also going to be something that operates
on a repository of these options the
only one that fits is fork let's double
check that this makes sense for king is
like cloning but with some extra steps
and you can only do it on github itself
it also takes a repository and makes
another repository so it does operate on
repositories all right let's move on
remember how we talked about pulling
combination of fetching and merging well
we have merge here so this will have to
be fetched let's check that this makes
sense we know that fetching is a part of
pull but does it operate on remotes and
branches it clearly operates on remotes
because you're fetching data from the
remote repository the connection to
branch is a little less clear you can
definitely fetch a particular branch
when you fetch the branch doesn't
necessarily get updated but remember
that we have references to the remote
versions of our branches and those are
the things that get updated so it does
operate on branches as well now it might
be tempting to put fast-forward merge
here since you would think fast forward
Marge would be related to merges but the
way that I think about fast-forward
merges is basically that they change
where a branch points so it takes a
branch label from one commit to another
commit so in my mind it just operates on
a branch we're down to one option and
only one spot left so this has got to be
where this guy goes let's check that
this actually makes sense when you make
a pull request you're asking to have a
particular branch be merged in with the
main branch or some other branch it
doesn't necessarily have to be master
and pull requests are a purely github
idea they don't exist and get proper so
merges are part of pull requests pull
requests work on branches you merge two
branches together and it's something
that's part of github so it all fits all
right we're done with the concept map
for this lesson